- So, you've never talked to these people
and this is the first
thing out of their mouth?
- Yes.
- We're here to discuss Tinder messages
that have been sent to me.
- This is gonna be awkward.
- She's about to find out
why I've been single for six years.
- I'm sorry, but you're about
to enter a world of hurt.
Yeah, this is real.
- No.
- I think that's a cute idea for a date.
(laughing)
- This is horrid.
(crickets chirping)
- I don't like that at all, F you.
- So he's had pee all over his face.
(laughing)
- It was completely different
than what I thought it was.
- You think about meeting somebody.
- Yeah.
- Okay?
And you, normally you say face to face,
"Hello, how are you doing?"
- Yeah.
- The first thing you say to somebody is
"Hey, you wanna (bleep)?"
- I don't understand how these people
expect for somebody to even comment back.
- I suspect some of this stuff works
for some of them with some people.
- Who? No.
- You won't be on Tinder anymore.
- I won't be on Tinder anymore.
- Okay.
- I won't be on Tinder.
For like a month.
- Marched around the White House.
Some guy climbed up the fence
and shouted out to the crowd,
"Does anybody wanna (bleep)?"
(laughing)
And one girl went.
- No!
(laughing)
- So, like I said, it
probably works for some.
(laughing)